[Music] It
's her. Don't get in her way. She blindsided my friends. I
knew it because she
tried to forcefully grab my arm. She
blinded me, so I love you guys.  I'll
just play with you, so what's the point of playing with you?
Which one is your girlfriend?
Just take her with you. Don't pretend that they're both my girlfriends.
No, really.  You're both my girlfriends, so why don't you just
kiss them right now? Show them you're
both my girlfriends. You
big bastard, in front of my real girlfriends.  You
can't kiss another woman Don't be silly, you're
not a fake Those kind of girls don't like it
[
Music]
That's fine We're both Rentaro Kokomasaaki I
'm your girlfriend These guys.  It's too much, I
can't see what's going on, but I can't see what happened these days.
Stop me, I'll kill you.